I've never seen Jamie Foxx and Katie
Holmes together ever
that's Claudia Jordan opening up to et
on Tuesday just hours after she
seemingly confirmed the romance between
her good friend Jamie Foxx and Katie
Holmes on the allegedly podcast with
Theo von and met you cold Weiss
do you like Katie Holmes he is very
happy with herself okay they're dating
yeah isn't it crazy like that he seems
very happy I guess people are really
wanting someone to confirm this and I'm
sorry but it's not coming from me I
don't have the knowledge of this being
fact I don't I misspoke
the reality star spoke carefully
insisting several times she could not
actually confirm whether Fox and Holmes
are a couple multiple sources have told
ET that the pair are in fact dating I
have no knowledge of Jamie was Kimmi at
all I've never seen them together uh
he's never told me he's dating her sorry
to like not have this um this bombshell
story but I cannot confirm that Fox has
denied the relationship to ET in the
past we've reached out again for comment
you